all right what up guys welcome to the
just pearly things YouTube channel and
welcome to morning coffee thoughts where
I give my thoughts on my way
either to get coffee or as I've got it I
live in the beautiful city of London
where there is literally trash
everywhere
I think because the trash people are on
strike
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel ring that notification
Bell okay trash okay
so I wanted to talk about this
phenomenon okay
um
men
shaming other men for not wanting to
take the risk of women in 2023. so I
want to paint a picture for you
and this picture I'm gonna acknowledge
not every woman is like this not every
woman will but mind you any woman can
so
basically we have this court system
right we have the system in court where
women are incentivized they're given
money
to leave marriages and they can do this
for any reason
they can do it because they're not happy
they can they can do it because they
want to eat pray love this [__] they can
do it because
um
really anything anytime that she feels
like it and the issue is a lot of states
in a lot of countries have incentives
for the women to accuse men of abuse
and what they've done is they've
expanded the definition of these things
so you know rape used to be forced sex
now it's sex without consent that makes
it very subjective to the point where
women that have been married for 10
years can come back cry and say oh I've
been raped what the [__] then why'd you
marry him like what that makes no sense
Okay so
and
um we have an entire Society
and media programming
that is telling women that the best
thing to do is to leave
and the media is also um
and the school system is also they
literally tell women that they've been
raped
if they um were drunk and had sex like
they do this in colleges So This Is How
Deeply programmed the women are
and we're just like dummies We Believe
goddamn anything so
um
okay you have a society telling women to
do the wrong thing then on top of that
you have payment programs for women to
do the wrong thing so hang them to
accuse men of abuse right
paying them
um to leave marriages
and
um
yeah I can I'm trying to think what else
so
essentially
now let's say
Trad can't say I don't understand stats
Pearl just can't do math and you know
fine I'm a woman whatever but so
they want to know where I got this 75
percent number
um as I've said it's roughly 50 50 on
marriages succeeding or failing right
and then out of the ones that stay
together marriage is a terrible
reputation in 2023 no it's not just the
people that I hang around most people I
grew up with were married but that was a
different time
um but there was a whole generation of
people
that have a negative view on marriage
what does that say the majority of
marriages that are still together
are not good
so that's 75 but let's just say pearls
being a Doomer super dramatic
you know not like not like I came up
with the phrase it's cheaper to keep her
not like I came up with the phrase
um happy wife happy life okay I didn't
come up with any of these things you
guys you guys just shoot the messenger
so okay
um
we have all this right but let's just
say Pearl's super dramatic and if you're
super religious
you only have a 10 chance of getting
forced and all of the numbers I've seen
it's more like 25 percent
and I could also give you anecdotal
experience of Christian women
that love Jesus
divorcing divorcing the [__] out of
there man
okay like I mean she's religious until
she's not I mean you think women they
convinced us not to work
um I mean they convinced us to go into
the workforce
um and not be with our children you
don't think they could convince you to
leave your husband
uh
I mean
we could do example after example Okay
so
let's say it's ten percent
so if you walked out a door
and you had a 10 chance of dying because
mind you this experience is like death
for a lot of men
and it's really easy to call them cry
babies or whiners or whatever when you
haven't talked to them
and which is why I keep saying spend a
day in family court but these are men
that a lot of times the woman tells
everybody that they're abusers again
look at Crowder no criminal case brought
against him yet his reputation is
practically destroyed
Okay so
um okay just just one example but on top
of that many of these guys get so
stressed out they lose their jobs
because or they have astronomical court
fees child support all that [__] you
know and a lot of guys will spend you
know the average guy makes what 50k a
year guys will spend 100 150k in court
fees just to not get their kids
and the thing is you can take money from
a guy
but there is something
about a man
who is so desperate to see his child
like it is the saddest thing you have
ever seen where his child will be a mile
from him and he hasn't seen him in two
years his child will be two miles from
this good Christian women do this
um
Muslim chicks do it like I I you name an
ethnicity a race uh anything I have seen
at all
I've seen it all and this is someone
that's researched it for a year imagine
what a divorce attorney has seen now
it's not that every chick's gonna do
this
but again
when a guy walks out a door let's just
say it's a 10 chance
and like this is uh of ever you have a
10 chance of everyone thinking you're an
abuser rapist which is horrible right
um not seeing your kids
your kids being raised by another guy
most likely
getting to see your kids every other
weekend
and being financially ruined
for the rest of your life because
most men and this is why this is what
started the whole conversation rich men
can recover a lot better from divorce
and this is just my experience it's the
average men that work in a factory or
have a normal nine to five
um that really get effed over
because the rich men
I mean don't get me wrong there's horror
stories there too but they at least tend
to be able to make money after the
divorce a guy that is one skill worked
the same job for 20 years
um
I mean what is he gonna do
like now he has to work the next job for
another 20 years to get back to where he
was at 46 years old
which is the average age of first
divorce for men
uh
I mean that's that's that sucks like you
know what I mean that's like a death
sentence in itself imagine it's really
indentured servitude when you think
about it so
this is what we're dealing with even if
it's a 10 chance
I
can't blame men for wanting to avoid
that risk
I can't and I and it's so funny because
they call me a Doomer but it's just so
clear that they have never like spoken
to these guys
because I I Pro I would pay you I would
pay you money to call them cry babies
um to a guy that hasn't seen his kid in
three years that everybody thinks he's a
rapist like that's a crybaby really and
I don't say this to be mean but they
just don't know what they're talking
about
um and it's not that every woman will
but it's around every woman can and okay
so let me get this straight the 60 to 80
year old men let's say 10 of them got
[__] now the women are
are worse in the Next Generation so
let's just say the 40 to 60 year old man
and I'm being conservative I'm going
with you guys the stupid stats
um 40 to 60 year old man 20 of them got
[__] because obviously the women are
worse every generation we just get worse
um
so now with let me let me get this
straight with the the social media age
where women are less are more
promiscuous than ever before are able to
hide Madness more than ever before
you're saying
just go to church hope she prays
and doesn't [__] you over
and
you know there's no real call for
divorce reform my argument is
you will not I don't care what you want
I don't even care what you preach you
will not see real families come back
together
until there is divorce reform because
men they'll weigh the pros they'll weigh
the cons and you're going to see more
and more men weighing the pros and the
cons and saying this is too risky
regardless of what I say
like I didn't I didn't make this mess I
was just born in this time period and
it's really interesting they're like
you're leading men to destruction I'm
like wow so my thing is
instead of getting mad at me
why don't you spend a day in divorce
court
and
see what I'm talking about
um
you know
and you say pearl Pearl why do you keep
tweeting about this you just have so
much free time I tweet for a living
and honestly I think this stuff is
important because what I don't want to
see is a 22 year old guy having no idea
what he's up against
no idea what he's signing up for
getting absolutely screwed in divorce
court because he was told to just go to
church and find a good chick
I mean I don't want to see if they weigh
the risks and rewards fine I got I got
no issues but it's when
it's when you guys
start to say oh
I'm just a doom and gloomer
and you insinuate that there's no reason
for men to be cautious
um but you know society's telling us to
do the wrong thing the media is telling
us to do the wrong thing and for
whatever reason when given Freedom we
just tend to do the wrong thing I don't
know why so you know guys like the video
maybe I'm just a doom and gloomer I
don't know and please stop taking these
screenshots
where you're like oh oh Pearl you know I
don't even care all right guys like the
video subscribe to the channel
um I'll talk to you next time